[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu einer Spezialausgabe von Fülle
nach acht fünf Köpfe 5 Meinungen seit
acht Tagen wütet Putins Krieg mehr als
eine Million Ukrainer sind auf der
Flucht und der ukrainische Präsident
selenski fordert zeigt dass ihr ein
Bündnis sein braucht es ein Putsch gegen
Putin warum greift die NATO nicht in den
ukrainekrieg ein was tut das
Verteidigungsbündnis aktuell und braucht
Deutschland jetzt das Gesellschaft sehr
für junge Menschen darüber möchte ich
mit meinen heutigen Gästen diskutieren
der ukrainische Botschafter andere manik
CDU-Politiker Christoph Ploss an meiner
Seite der stellvertretende
bildchefredakteur der ist noch nicht da
aber dafür ist Peter hell schon da der
ist uns auch zugeschaltet aus der
Ukraine hallo Peter schön dass du dabei
bist Paul folgt später
genau und dann haben wir noch last but
not least den will ich jetzt natürlich
nicht vergessen unseren cool
Journalisten Hans Ulrich Jörges lassen
Sie uns keine Zeit verlieren und lassen
Sie uns direkt mal fragen bei Peter du
bist gerade in Ukraine wo bist du du
hast hier verlassen wie war die Route
aus Kiew raus und wie ist die Lage
aktuell in der Ukraine
also ich fange mal an wo wir sind und
ich möchte erst morgen bei dem
Botschafter für meine Aussprache sind in
der kriminitzki ich hoffe das ist
richtig ausgesprochen
wir sind gestern aus Kiew raus in frühen
Morgenstunden es war sehr gespenstisch
muss ich sagen wir hatten um 7 Uhr haben
wir Abfahrt gehabt sind durch eine
Geisterstadt Gefahren an mehreren
Checkpoints vorbei man merkt Kias ist in
einem kompletten
Schockzustand nachts die Bombardements
dauernd gehen die Sirenen auf den
Straßen sind keine Menschen es ist eine
gespenstische Ruhe die sich dadurch
diese engen Straßen zieht Checkpoints
überall also man wartet im Prinzip auf
den
Feuersturm der hoffentlich nie eintreten
wird aber wir befürchten schlimmstes wir
sind dann raus und wir sind dann in eine
Stadtausfahrt gekommen wo man gemerkt
hat okay hier bereitet man sich auf das
Schlimmste vor es werden Gräben
ausgehoben es werden Schutz
[Musik]
Peter wir haben gerade ein wenig
Verbindungsschwierigkeiten ich würde
direkt Herr menik fragen wie seine
Einschätzung auch ist wie es gerade um
die Ukraine steht
also die Lage ist in der Tat immer
dramatischer mit mit jedem mit jedem Tag
für die Menschen und zwar nicht nur in
der Hauptstadt sondern auch vor allem im
Osten im
Nordosten aber auch im Süden da wo die
Russen im Moment ziemlich weit
vordringen konnten
und das Schlimmste ist dass die Menschen
dass die Menschen
nicht nur die Soldaten aber vor allem
die Menschen zerbombt werden und dass
sie jetzt
zu Geiseln genommen werden von von
diesen vorrückenden Truppen aber vor
allem von den Raketenwerfern und von der
Luftwaffe denn die die tödlichsten Stöße
die kommen vom vom Himmel und das ist
natürlich das Schlimmste an diesem an
diesem Krieg dass das die Zivilisten die
ersten Opfer dieses
Vernichtungskrieges geworden sind und
deswegen haben wir schon seit dem ersten
Tag seit acht Jahren fordern wir von
unseren Partnern in der NATO eine no fly
Zone zu errichten damit zumindest die
Zivilisten in Schutz genommen werden
können und damit auch Atomkraftwerke
heute ist das größte Atomkraftwerk in
Europa in der Stadt Ernährung da wurde
auch von den russischen Truppen
verläufig besetzt
ist nicht mehr unter unserer Kontrolle
was geschieht da das heißt da müssen
muss sie jetzt nachgedacht werden
natürlich wollen wir nicht dass die NATO
jetzt in diesen Krieg einsteigt das ist
natürlich die Gefahr ist da aber es muss
eine kreative Lösung gefunden werden wie
man wie man dieses Morden vom Himmel
verhindert auch der ukrainische
Präsident silence Gerd heute auf einer
geheimen Pressekonferenz gesprochen
pauronsheimer ist jetzt auch bei uns im
Studio zumindest digital ist er ab jetzt
auch die ganze Sendung dabei ich sehe
ihn hier neben mir und deswegen vielen
herzlichen Dank an Peter hell für die
Einschätzung und jetzt möchten wir
natürlich auch direkt die Einschätzung
von paronsheimer hören und Paul erzähl
uns doch auch bitte von dem was selensky
heute in der geheimpressekonferenz
gesagt hat
ja Nina es war sicherlich eine der
ungewöhnlichsten Begegnungen die ich
jemals in Kiew hatte und zwar deshalb
weil ich schon häufig in diesem
präsidentengebäude war 2014 häufig
petropolschenko interviewt habe dann
selenski bereits interviewt habe aber
als ich dort heute hinkam mit
wahnsinnigen Sicherheitsvorkehrungen und
dann in dieses präsidentengebäude
gegangen bin da war das Licht
ausgeschaltet man ist fast über die
Treppen gestolpert weil zu dunkel war
dann lagen Sandsäcke überall das muss
man sich so ein bisschen vorstellen als
würde im Kanzleramt plötzlich kein Licht
mehr scheinen und Olaf Scholz sich
irgendwo verstecken und auf geheimen
Wege werden dort Journalisten
reingebracht damit es eine
kriegspressekonferenz geben könnte das
war so ein Fall dann saßen die
Journalisten
einzelne eingeladene Journalisten in
diesem Raum der wiederum relativ normal
aussah und dann kam selenski dort rein
und er machte
trotz dieses Krieges trotz dieser
persönlichen Bedrohung auch für ihn
selbst denn er steht ja auf einer
Todesliste ganz weit oben an Platz 1
wahrscheinlich von Wladimir Putin nahm
sich einen Stuhl und hat sich direkt vor
die Journalisten gesetzt er weiß
natürlich wie Inszenierung funktioniert
als ehemaliger Schauspieler auch als
Präsident mittlerweile weiß er das wie
man mit Bildern umgeht aber es war so
eine Unterschied zu den Bildern die man
von Wladimir Putin kennt auch die
Pressekonferenz oder die Ansprache die
Putin vorhin gehalten hat wo er wieder
gedroht hat und gesagt hat der Krieg
geht weiter wo er gesagt hat dass er die
Ukraine für Nazis hält und deswegen die
Russen und Ukrainer vereint werden
müssen und die Nazis bekämpft werden
müssen diese absurde Schwachsinn ist zu
nett ausgedrückt diese grauenhaften
Lügen die Wladimir Putin über die
Ukraine verbreitet und dagegen selensky
der mir dann gegenüber saß und wir
kennen uns von früheren Interviews und
ich habe ihn dann gefragt how are you
und
hat nur gesagt nur Bett und hat mir die
Hand gereicht und wir haben kurz die
Hände geschüttelt und man erlebt ein
Präsidenten der wirklich über sich
hinauswächst und er hat dann wieder sehr
klar adressiert was notwendig ist aus
seiner Sicht er hat klar gemacht dass
das Land kämpfen wird dass sie nicht
aufgeben werden er hat gesagt wenn er
nicht Präsident wäre dann wäre er auch
in einer zivilen verteidigungseinheit er
hat gesagt dass er Unterstützung will
eine no fly so und sicherlich eine
unrealistische Forderung dennoch hat er
das klar gemacht und er hat einen Satz
gesagt den ich ja sehr wichtig finde
vielleicht auch jetzt hier für die
Diskussion er hat gesagt wenn Putin dort
nicht gestoppt wird wenn es nicht
geschafft wird Putin in der Ukraine zu
stoppen dann sind die nächsten Länder
die baltischen Staaten und irgendwann
steht Putin dann in Berlin er hat gesagt
er stünde dann würde bis zur Berliner
Mauer gehen also er meint sozusagen das
ehemalige Ostberlin das sind Dinge die
vom Monaten Jahren andere Politiker
gesagt haben aber Nena nachdem all das
wahr geworden ist was ja die größten
Pessimisten wie wir vielleicht und
andere angenommen haben was Putin machen
würde hört man ganz genau hin wenn dann
diese Sätze kommen
das kann ich mir absolut vorstellen Paul
und es ist also ich weiß gar nicht was
man dabei empfindet wenn man zu so einer
geheimen Pressekonferenz geht
Christoph du nimmst alles auch sehr Wahl
in Ukraine Konflikt dass das Paul gerade
erklärt hat wir haben gerade über die no
flyzone gesprochen sollten wir die
umsetzen
etwas heikle Frage weil es auch Öl ins
Feuer gießen kann aber ich kann die
Argumente des Herrn Botschafters sehr
gut nachvollziehen weil die Russen ja
nicht nur militärische Angriffe verüben
wie sie selber in ihrer Propaganda
behaupten sondern leider auch sehr viele
Angriffe auf Zivilisten vornehmen
Krankenhäuser mittlerweile bombardieren
nicht ganz normale Wohnhäuser
unschuldige Menschen und
dieses Treiben was Putin da mittlerweile
seit gut einer Woche macht diesen
treiben kann man nicht zusehen deswegen
halte ich schon für notwendig dass wir
dieses Thema auch stärker hier in den
Fokus der deutschen und auch
europäischen Politik nehmen aber es ist
eine schwierige Abwägung das muss man
auch klar sagen weil Putin ja
mittlerweile auch sogar mit atomaren
Angriffen droht ganz bewusst auch diese
Schreckenszenario aufbaut und wir alle
wissen noch aus der Zeit des Kalten
Krieges wenn einer mein falschen Knopf
drückt oder irgendwo was ausrutscht dann
kann das ganz schnell zu einer großen
Katastrophe führen deswegen ist im
Moment das wirklich sehr sehr schwierig
auch die richtigen Entscheidungen da zu
treffen ich wollte noch einmal auch Paul
ronsheimer Fragen der da ja wirklich im
Moment
im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes an der
Front steht und auch wirklich
hervorragenden Journalismus macht ganz
live dabei ist ich hoffe auch dass er
dafür ein Reporterpreis und
Journalistenpreis bekommt das hat er auf
jeden Fall verdient aber mich würde mal
interessieren was die Ukraine weiter an
Waffen braucht oder wie sich das auch in
den nächsten Tagen möglicherweise
entwickeln könnte denn als vor gut einer
Woche Putin mit dem Angriff begonnen hat
da haben in Deutschland ja sehr viele
gesagt
defensiv Waffen an die Ukraine zu
liefern das bringt er gar nichts mehr
weil das sowieso nach zwei oder drei
Tagen alles vorbei ist und jetzt sehen
wir die Ukraine die haben da wirklich
einen historischen Kampf die kämpfen wie
die besten die machen das super und es
gibt ganz viel Unterstützung auch aus
der Welt und mittlerweile ja auch die
Hoffnung dass die Ukraine den Kampf
vielleicht sogar gewinnen können was man
von der Woche nie gedacht hätte
inwiefern würden weitere
defensivwaffenlieferungen helfen das
würde mich noch mal interessieren weil
das ja auch für die Entscheidung hier in
Deutschland von großer Bedeutung ist
ich glaube sie sprechen da ein sehr
wichtigen Punkt an und zunächst einmal
muss man sagen das glaube ich ganz viele
Politiker zum Beispiel Frau Strack
Zimmermann von der FDP und andere die
gesagt haben und in einer zynischen Art
und Weise gesagt haben na ja jetzt ist
das ja so und die Russen haben eben eine
militärische Übermacht und was sollen
wir dann noch hinliefern ich glaube
diese Politiker die sollten sich ganz
dringend bei anderen Melnik dem
ukrainischen Botschafter entschuldigen
und Frau stark Zimmermann ist da nicht
die erste nicht die einzige der kommen
noch ganz viele dazu kommen auch von
ihrer Partei und von der SPD die sollten
gesammelt dort bei der Botschaft
vorstellig werden bei André manic und
sich entschuldigen bei ihm denn erst der
Mann der über monatelang immer wieder
gesagt hat wir brauchen diese Waffen
laut und deutlich hat er das gesagt
niemand wollte ihm zuhören niemand aus
dieser Politik hat ihn wirklich ernst
genommen niemand hat sich dem angenommen
und das ist für mich eigentlich ein
Skandal der noch aufgearbeitet werden
muss aber jetzt ist es so wie es ist und
was gut ist
muss man sagen ist das wieder Waffen
gekommen sind aus Deutschland und worum
geht es vor allem das muss man den
Zuschauern auch erklären es geht vor
allem um die Abwehr von Raketen die
Abwehr von Marschflugkörpern es geht um
Flugabwehr das ist ja etwas was Putin
bislang zumindest in Kiew noch nicht
eingesetzt hat er hat ja alle
Möglichkeiten aus der Luft Kiew so zu
bombardieren wie er zum Beispiel Aleppo
bombardiert hat und dann kann ich Ihnen
sagen bleibt von dieser Stadt nichts
mehr übrig dann wäre hier alles Schutt
und Asche und dann reden wir über 10.000
und 100.000 Tote ich wollte was
einwenden gegen den Begriff der defensiv
Waffen den kann ich nicht mehr hören die
Gefahr ist doch nicht dass die Ukraine
Russland angreift also dass man sich
also auf Kleinwaffen beschränken muss
die Ukraine muss möglichst wirkungsvoll
bewaffnet werden und ewiges bei einer
Flugverbotszone zu Luftkämpfen zwischen
NATO Flugzeugen und russischen
Flugzeugen kommen lassen das wäre der
Gang in den in den atomaren Krie glaube
ich in ein riesen Eskalation muss die
Ukraine in die Lage versetzt werden
durch moderne Waffensysteme nicht nur
durch schultergestützte
kleinraketen die auf Flugzeuge
angeschlossen werden soll natürlich
richtige wirkungsvolle
luftabwehrbatterien sich zur Wehr zu
setzen und die müssen natürlich an allen
größeren Städten sein und es wird
höchste Zeit dass die geliefert werden
ob die ursprünglich für defensive oder
Offensive Aufgaben gedacht sind ist mir
völlig wurscht sie müssen wirken und ich
möchte den Begriff von defensivwaffen
nicht mehr hören die Ukraine wird
Russland nie angreifen
es ist auch ihre Meinung dazu wir haben
gerade vor dieser Sendung habe ich eine
lange lange Liste eine neue Liste von
den Waffensystemen die wir gerade jetzt
brauchen an das Verteidigungsministerium
und anders Auswärtige Amt geschickt und
da ist die Frage von defensiv oder
offensiv Waffen nicht so relevant wir
verteidigen uns seit acht Tagen wir sind
auf unserem Boden wir haben nicht vor
jemanden anzugreifen und auch nicht vor
die Gebiete die bereits vor diesem
Angriff besetzt waren von Russen die
Creme und Donbass auch nicht
zurückeroben mit den Waffen aber was wir
wollen wir wollen das lebende Zivilisten
schützen wir wollen
wir wollen dieses Systeme zum Beispiel
patchworketten also die die hart man
hier in Deutschland die werden jetzt
auch ins Baltikum versetzt das braucht
man auch um die verbünden zu schützen
aber vielleicht gibt es auch eine
Überlegung also was was kommt als erstes
also wir sind jetzt schon angegriffen
worden und das heißt da müssen wir nicht
nur jetzt die vielleicht so sehr die
Bundeswehr oder das
Verteidigungsministerium in Pflicht
nehmen sondern auch die deutsche
Rüstungsindustrie wir führen jetzt
Gespräche was da noch geliefert werden
kann kurzfristig um um die Menschen zu
schützen aber auch dann vielleicht auch
mittelfristig um die
Verteidigungsfähigkeiten zu stärken in
der Ukraine und das wäre auch die
Botschaft einen Putin wo er dann
vielleicht doch davon absieht meine
meine Lieblingsstadt Türkei auf meine
Heimat zu zerbomben wie Aleppo oder wie
andere Städte die schon ja ihrem
Schicksal
erlegen mussten deswegen danke für diese
Unterstützung wir wir brauchen das wir
hoffen dass die Bundesregierung sich
nicht so viel Zeit nehmen wird um diese
Liste zu prüfen es muss schnellstens
agiert werden das heißt wir erwarten
eine Antwort in den nächsten Tagen
kommen weil das ist bei für den dass
jeder etwas mitbringen kann was ihn
aufregt habe ich noch eine letzte Frage
an Herr manik und ich wünsche mir nur
einen Namen zu hören also einen Namen
eine kurze Antwort Herr räumst ja mal
eben angesprochen Politiker sollten sich
bei Ihnen entschuldigen wer von wem
erwarten sie denn eine Entschuldigung
gibt es einen Politiker wo sie sagen ja
das stimmt der sollte sich wirklich mal
entschuldigen nein also ich als
Botschafter erwartet man keine
Entschuldigung und man erwartet
richtiges Handeln und das ist das was
ich erwarte also wir haben über
zeitenwände jetzt alle gehörte am am an
diesem Sonntag in der besonderen Sitzung
des Bundestages aber vier Tage sind
vergangen und es ist noch bei uns
zumindest nicht angekommen ja diese
diese
richtig daneben lag wo sie sagen also
dieser Politiker der hätte sich schon
mal anders äußern können
es ist eine viel zu lange Liste und die
Sendung würde vielleicht zu lange dauern
weil es waren ja nicht nur Politiker
also es waren viele Menschen die einfach
nicht glauben wollten auch wir wollen
nicht glauben dass es nicht so dass wir
irgendwie
apokalyptische gedacht haben
Bundesregierung anfangens die gesamte
Regierung lag schief ja und und das
betrifft auch die die brokkos also auch
die die vorigen Regierungen weil hätte
man diese Schritte im Jahre 14 nach der
Krämern Lektion
eingeleitet und und hätten man uns
bewaffnet dann wäre es wäre zum
vielleicht zu diesem Krieg in diesem
Ausmaß gekommen und dann glaube ich dass
wir doch immer noch in einer friedlichen
Ukraine leben würden aber wie gesagt es
ist schnell von gestern heute zählt was
heute in diesem nächsten Tagen geschieht
was die Regierung macht welche Waffen
wir bekommen können und zwar sehr
schnell denn sehr wichtig sie haben
gesehen die Ukraine sind bereit sich zu
verteidigen das ist die Botschaft und
die auch unguten Tradition gebrochen
werden müssen wir ja schon sagen dass
die Waffenhilfe am besten immer zu spät
kommt immer zu spät also immer eine
Phase zu spät jetzt wo die großen Städte
bedrängt werden müssten doch längst
radargestützte Luftabwehrsysteme dort
sein um die Städte zu verteidigen
vielleicht kommen die irgendwann aber
dann weiß ich nicht in welchem Zustand
Kiew ist bevor wir jetzt in die Debatte
gehen schlage ich ihn jemanden vorher
menik ich finde nämlich dass dieser sich
nicht nur bei Ihnen entschuldigen sollte
sondern auch bei allen deutschen ehrlich
gesagt für das was er alles so gemacht
hat zu wem er gehalten hat und wo er so
im Aufsichtsrat sitzt mein Thema heute
Abend ist Gerhard Schröder die
SPD-Spitze hat Altkanzler Schröder
zurecht nämlich jetzt ein Ultimatum sein
Posten Verzicht gestellt
SPD-Vorsitzende Lars klingbar und Saskia
esken haben den früheren Parteichef und
Bundeskanzler Gerd Schröder in einem
Brief ultimativ endlich in meinen Augen
dazu aufgefordert seine Posten bei
russischen Staatsunternehmen
niederzulegen man erwarte eine zeitnah
Antwort das hat Lars Klingbeil heute auf
einer gemeinsamen digitalen
Pressekonferenz mit Ästen einer Sitzung
des Parteivorstands gesagt sollte
Schröder der Aufforderung die bereits am
vergangenen Samstag erfolgt sei nicht
nachkommen werde man über das weitere
Vorgehen beraten Schröder sei Zitat
komplett isoliert in der
Sozialdemokratie sagte klingball ich
kann nur sagen endlich er hat auch
gesagt im Parteivorstand gäbe es
niemanden mehr der Schröders Verhalten
auch nur ansatzweise gut heißt oder
rechtfertigt nicht nur die SPD
distanziert sich von Gerd Schröder die
Stadt Hannover will Altkanzler Gerd
Schröder die Ehrenbürger würde entziehen
ein entsprechenden Schluß der
Verwaltungsausschuss am Donnerstagabend
einstimmig gefasst und damit es
offizielle Verfahren eingeleitet
voraussichtlich am 31 März wird dann im
Rat darüber entschieden aber ich frage
mich wie lange wird Schröder diesen
Druck der noch durchhalten Uli ich nenne
das verlogen ist mal klar zu sagen
niemand hinter die Bundesregierung und
die Mehrheit im Bundestag daran ein
Gesetz zu erlassen dass es deutschen
generell untersagt Führungspositionen in
russischen Unternehmen
auszuüben das sollte längst passiert
sein da muss man nicht an Schröder
appellieren dass er irgendwann von
alleine geht man muss es ihm einfach
verbieten und dann ist der Fall erledigt
aber das tut natürlich deshalb keiner
weil Deutschland und die Bundesliga
machen ja weiterhin Geschäfte mit der
Gasform sie importieren ja russisches
Gas also wie sollen sie dann als
Regierung gleichzeitig den Mann
verbieten bei der Gasbrenner Funktion
auszuüben ich komme da noch drauf später
die deutsche Politik ist aus meiner
Sicht verlogen immer noch nicht ehrlich
und das merken wir auch am falschen
Schröder
lassen Sie also wir alle sollten einmal
beim Fall Schröder finde ich direkt
bleiben weil es Altkanzler verbieten
hier ist vor allem man muss ja vor allem
auch noch ein ganz besonderen
Hintergrund er ist ja nicht ein ganz
normaler Bürger der keine Leistung vom
Staat bekommt und irgendwie guckt wo
kann er Geld verdienen dann wäre das
schon schlimm genug aber er bekommt ja
mehrere hunderttausend Euro über
Mitarbeiter über jedes Jahr eine
entsoldung eine Entlohnung bis ans
Lebensende die der deutsche Steuer damit
genau da muss ich mal vom deutschen
Steuerzahler und der Hintergrund dieser
Entlohnung und auch dieses
Mitarbeiterstab ist und der
Infrastruktur die er vom deutschen
Steuerzahler bekommt ist ja dass er den
deutschen Staat auch als Altkanzler
repräsentiert so wie das viele
Altkanzler und auch Altbundespräsidenten
immer gemacht haben und das hat ja mit
Repräsentanz nichts zu tun das
beschädigt Deutschland
politisch im Ansehen in der ganzen Welt
und deswegen ist es überfällig dass
diese Gelder vom deutschen Steuerzahler
sofort eingestellt werden bei den
nächsten Haushaltsberatungen muss eines
klar gestellt werden Gerhard Schröder
darf kein Büro mehr finanziert bekommen
keine Mitarbeiter mehr finanziert
bekommen und auch sein der Entlohnung
die er bis ans Lebensende als Altkanzler
eigentlich bekommt die müssten
eingestellt werden da steht ein bisschen
Kopf wir lassen also weiter zu dass er
bei der Gazprom und bei der Rosneft in
den Aufsichtsräten sitzt und neben dem
hier seine seine Geld da weg wir müssen
ihm das verbieten und ich bin sogar
überzeugt
als Bürger wenn ein deutscher
Staatsbürger sagt er will nach Russland
ziehen
aber das kann man ja nicht verbieten
aber der entscheidende
aber mir geht's also mir geht es ja
darum dass man sagt der deutsche
Steuerzahler darf kein Euro mehr an
Gerhard Schröder bezahlen und ausgeben
für Gerhard Schröders Infrastruktur und
wenn
immer noch Kopf man muss verbieten dass
der Mann für Russland arbeitet das ist
der zentrale das können sie nicht in der
wir leben ja innerhalb Demokratie und
jeder hat Sitzung kann man das
beschließen und ich halte sogar für
möglich dass er irgendwo dankbar ist
weil ihm die Entscheidung abgenommen
wird er fühlt sich doch aber das geht
das geht rechtlich nicht also sie
könnten man könnte ihn man könnte ihn ja
auch nicht verbieten für Gazprom zu
arbeiten wenn Sie sich jetzt nach der
Sendung entscheidender Moskau zu ziehen
und für gastron zu arbeiten ist das ihr
Recht was aber man politisch entscheiden
kann ist dass sie nicht auch noch Gelder
vom deutschen Steuer Sanktionen gegen
Russland warum soll das als Sanktion
nicht möglich sein natürlich ist das
möglich es ist sehr viel möglich auch
das es ist eine Form von Schröders
Unterstützung für das Krieg führende
Russland das kann man verbieten ich
vermute mal dass er auch deshalb so
loyal an Putin hängt weil er seinen
Fehler einfach nicht eingestehen will
und weil ihm Putin Adoptivkinder besorgt
hat spielt in seinem Leben eine große
Rolle nehmen wir ihm die Entscheidung ab
verbieten aus Schluss vergesst Schröder
eine darf nicht mehr für Russland haben
eine
eine Frage dazu die mich interessiert
weil mich das ganze auch sehr
beschäftigt hat obwohl ich hier bin weil
ich mit Gerhard Schröder sozusagen
politisch aufgewachsen bin mich von da
an für Politik interessiert habe als er
Kanzler wurde kurz zuvor und wenn man
sich überlegt was das Ganze jetzt für
ihn bedeutet er wurde bei Borussia
Dortmund
wurde ihm glaube ich die Mitgliedschaft
entzogen er kriegt den Druck bei der SPD
da muss man ja eine Sache auch noch
wissen Lars klingball und Gerhard
Schröder waren einmal
Ängst befreundet bis vor wenigen Wochen
bis dieser Krieg ausgebrochen ist bzw
eskaliert ist Last klingball hat man bei
Gerhard Schröder im Büro gearbeitet
Gerhard Schröder hat in seinem
Bundestagswahlkampf Wahlkampf gemacht
und so weiter und so fort auch das ein
Zerwürfnis er ist bei Ringier
rausgeflogen er steht in der
Öffentlichkeit als Buhmann da diejenigen
die ihn vorher noch verteidigt haben
haben sich abgewendet spätestens seitdem
Wladimir Putin hier Zivilisten in der
Ukraine bom passiert warum macht er das
wirklich ich frage mich mittlerweile hat
Vladimir Putin und damit will ich
Gerhard Schröder nicht in Schutz nehmen
aber ich frage mich das hat Wladimir
Putin irgendetwas gegen ihn in der Hand
denn ansonsten macht das doch für einen
politisch denkenden Mensch auch wenn er
dann glauben sollte dass er irgendwie
Wladimir Putin mag warum auch immer ja
ich meine es ist ein Kriegsverbrecher
aber
es würde doch
ist logisch spricht nichts mehr dafür
dass Gerhard Schröder weiter daran
festhält vielleicht Uli Jörges erkennt
den wahrscheinlich am längsten
ich habe hier schon gesagt ich vermute
dass hinter seiner anhaltenden Loyalität
zu Putin auch die Kinderfrage steckt er
sie im wahnsinnig persönlich nah und er
ist ein Typ der einfach Fehler nicht
eingestehen kann er hat nie einen Fehler
eingestanden er bringt es nicht fertig
das muss man ihm abnehmen man muss ihn
da rausholen verbieten und dann in
Hannover wo er lebt vergessen dann soll
er sich überlegen wann er zurückkommt in
die Öffentlichkeit mit welcher Erklärung
aber jedenfalls dass die SPD nun Appelle
an ihn richtet finde ich völlig daneben
die SPD soll dafür sorgen dass das nicht
mehr tun darf darauf persönlich
enttäuscht mit einem Tisch gegenüber zum
Beispiel da warst du ja gar nicht so
stark gegen Schröder wie es jetzt toll
beispielsweise schon vor Wochen war ist
es auch eine persönliche Enttäuschung
wenn man jemanden lange ich bin auch
sehr persönlich enttäuscht von Russland
das werde ich gleich noch erläutern
meine Position hat sich in vielen Fragen
verändert auch direkt auch meine
Funktion meine meine Position zu Waffen
zu Waffenlieferung ich bin 100% davon
überzeugt dass die Ukraine wirklich
wirksame Waffen aus dem Westen kriegen
muss und nicht nur kleine neues Gerät
das ist immer noch völlig hinter der
Zeit her ich will folgendes sagen lass
uns direkt zu deiner ich sehe nur einen
Ausweg aus der aus der Situation ich
habe in den letzten Tagen mehrfach
Diskussionen erlebt wo es immer um die
Frage ging wie können wir wieder ein
Gespräch mit Putin kommen und was können
wir ihm anbieten meine Antwort lautet
nichts die Gespräche mit Putin sind zu
Ende Putin muss gestürzt werden durch
einen Putsch in Moskau und dafür muss
der Westen die Voraussetzungen schaffen
durch die schärfsten denkbaren
Sanktionen die man überhaupt verhängen
kann davon sind wir noch weit entfernt
damit die Macht Elite in Moskau brüchig
wird und sich überlegt wie lange sie
noch loyal mit Putin ist und damit sich
dann Dinge in Gang setzen die wir die
mit dem Untergang Putins Enden drei
Punkte will ich nennen erstens wir
sollten sofort den Import von Gas-
Kommission hat schon vor Tagen errechnet
dass diese Importe zu kompensieren
werden aus anderen Quellen da werden die
Energiepreise steigen aber dieses Land
ist reich genug um einen sozialen
Ausgleich für ärmer Menschen zu finden
erster Punkt zweiter Punkt
es ist ja nur ein kleiner Teil der
russischen Banken von dem Bankensystem
Swift ausgeschlossen es ist ein Viertel
man glaubt es gar nicht und der Westen
tut so als Seins fast alle ein Viertel
ist ausgeschlossen unter anderem ist die
gazprombank immer noch in diesem System
und zwar deshalb weil die Deutschen für
ihre Energieimporte gerne über die
gazpromgeschäfte mit Russland machen
dafür kann ich mich nur schämen ich
finde es empörend und ich muss sagen es
ist der Gipfel der Verlogenheit dass wir
auf der einen Seite Waffen an die
Ukraine liefern und auf der anderen
Seite mit deutschem Öl und gasgeld die
russische Kriegsmaschine geschmiert wird
das kann doch wohl nicht im Ernst sein
wir müssen uns dafür eine Seite
entscheiden und die eine Seite jetzt in
diesem Weg ist die Ukraine dritter Punkt
ich bin überzeugt davon dass wir zu
einem generellen
handelsenbargo geschäftsembargo mit
Russland übergehen sollten keine Importe
mehr keine Exporte mehr Russland total
isoliert und es gibt große deutsche
Unternehmen die schon vorangehen die
Autokonzerne liefern keine Autos mehr
nach Russland siemens hat beschlossen
Russland zu verlassen und keiner
Aufträge von dort mehr entgegenzunehmen
das ist der richtige Weg und das nur das
bringt glaube ich Menschen in Russland
in im Militär in den Geheimdiensten dazu
über die Frage nachzudenken ob sie nicht
besser Putin abräumen müssten um ihr um
ihr Land vor schwerem Schaden zu
bewahren und falls Putin falls das
passiert und Putin hinterher noch lebt
dann muss der Westen darauf bestehen
dass er nach Den Haag ausgeliefert wird
an den Internationalen Gerichtshof der
dort Kriegsverbrechen und Angriffskriege
behandelt wie er das schon gegen
serbische Kriegsverbrecher getan hat
jedenfalls bin ich der Meinung kein
Zurück zu Putin Putin muss weg
Paul Ulli ich kann nur sagen so
schwierig die Lage hier auch ist und so
dramatisch die Lage ist finde ich freue
ich mich dass du jetzt auch bei der
Ukraine Politik auf den richtigen Weg
gefunden hast auch wenn es ein bisschen
gedauert hat leider
ja ja nein es ist es ist es ist nur
sozusagen auch symbolisch ein bisschen
da wir haben ja viel über Russland und
die Ukraine in den vergangenen Wochen
und Monaten immer wieder gestritten ich
frage mich halt was wäre passiert und
auch diese Frage muss man glaube ich mal
erörtern wenn du wenn andere wenn viele
Politiker schon früher in diese Richtung
gedacht hätten ob es dann sozusagen
diese Katastrophe nicht gegeben hätte
und gleichzeitig frage ich mich
gibt es überhaupt eine Chance dass das
so passiert wie du sagst also das
Wladimir Putin wirklich stürzen kann da
bin ich unsicher weil ich glaube dass
sozusagen alle Generäle um ihn herum
alle Geheimdienstler all diejenigen die
ihnen die eher groß gemacht hat große
Sorge haben mit ihm zusammen zu stürzen
und das bedeutet dass der
geheimdienstbereich dass der
Militärbereich um ihn herum ein
Interesse daran hat dass er bleibt und
das ist das glaube ich tragische
und wenn wir sehen dass selbst auch
Oligarchen
was man zumindest liest natürlich
unglücklich sind darüber wie es verläuft
aber es nicht schaffen werden im ihn zu
stürzen muss man davon ausgehen dass er
bleibt und wenn wir die Rede hören über
die wir vielleicht gleich auch noch
sprechen können oder die Ansprache die
er gehalten hat dann muss an das
wirklich erschaudern lassen und
tatsächlich zittern lassen
davor was er noch mit der Ukraine vor
hat lieber also mit welcher über Paul
ich kann Totalität ich teile deine
Bedenken zum Teil ich stelle aber fest
es ist völlig unmöglich dass die Ukraine
den Krieg gegen Russland gewinnt das
sind die größten Verhältnisse einfach zu
zu stark das heißt da muss der Westen
eine entscheidende Rolle spielen ich
gebe dir zu dass ich mich in der Politik
Russlands und Putins getäuscht habe ich
dachte es geht in Wahrheit um die
Osterweiterung der NATO da hat der
besten 1990 nach der deutschen
Wiedervereinigung Fehler gemacht da hat
der Russland getäuscht aber heute bin
ich froh dass es die Osterweiterung
überhaupt gegeben hat denn sonst wären
diese Länder
Russland im Prinzip ausgeliefert auch
also ich habe erkannt aber was ist die
Argumentation mit der Nahrung wenn ich
dir eine Frage stellen kann ja mach mal
eine Frage weil du es gerade ansprichst
weil ich ja vorhin auch über die Rede
von den oder meine die Antwort von
Präsident selensky auf meine Frage
gesprochen hat hältst du es denn für
völlig unrealistisch das selensky das
insgesamt das Wladimir Putin am Ende
wenn er mit der Ukraine fertig ist nicht
tatsächlich nach NATO starten greifen
wird also wer sagt ihm denn dass die
NATO wirklich bereit steht wenn dann ein
vermeintlich kleines Land wie Estland
also in den baltischen Staaten
angegriffen werden würden das glaube ich
nicht und ich will dir das auch
begründen er hat doch inzwischen
mehrfach programmatisch Erklärungen
abgegeben ich glaube dass er eher dran
denkt ehemalige Staaten der Sowjetunion
wieder zurück zu erobern das fängt an
mit Georgien und das ist nicht Mitglied
der NATO und ginge dann theoretisch
weiter in Missel mittelasiatischen
Staaten an den baltischen Staaten glaube
ich wird er sich nicht vergreifen weil
er eben scheut davor sich mit der NATO
anzulegen auch dass die ukrainische
Grenze nach Westen von russischen
Truppen nicht abgeriegelt wird ist ja
ein Zeichen dafür dass er dort mit der
NATO nicht in Konflikt geraten will
Spiel eben auch überleben und das müssen
wir eben glaube ich durch andere Mittel
davon habe ich gesprochen unmöglich
machen er darf keinen zweiten Krieg
führen und er darf diesen Krieg nicht
gewinnen er muss untergehen und wenn er
nicht und wenn er nicht sozusagen lebend
ausgeschaltet wird dann muss eben einer
im Moskauer Machtsystem eine Pistole
nehmen und der Sachen Ende bereiten wir
machen aus dem Einzel von euch beiden
mal einen Doppel und ging mal wieder
rüber zu Herr
Professoren die Frage die sich natürlich
auch sehr sehr viele Europäer stellen
ist wird die Ukraine Wladimir Putin
überhaupt reichen wenn er sie erobert
hat
ich kann die Meinung von Herrn Jürgens
in dieser Frage also nicht teil in dem
Sinne des die Ukraine diesen Kampf
verlieren kann also sie darf ihn nicht
verlieren denn wenn wenn das geschieht
dann wird es keine Ukraine geben denn
ihm geht es nicht nur um um Besetzung
von von Gebieten ihm geht um das
Zerschlagen der Staatlichkeit und das
heißt und und und und deswegen wir
wissen davon und egal welche zu
Geständnisse jetzt von uns verlangt oder
was uns nahegelegt wird auch hier in
Berlin dann man sollte sich bewegen da
ist die Frage die Antwort es gibt nichts
was Putin zufriedenstellen würde damit
er loslässt und deswegen so vielleicht
um das Thema Herr Schröder abzuschließen
wir hätten für ihn und alle
Beleidigungen also das bleibt in der
Vergangenheit auch für uns aber er hätte
vielleicht doch einen letzte Aufgabe
also er ist einer der wenigen
hier in Deutschland oder vielleicht der
vielen Politiker die womöglich noch
einen direkten Draht zu einem Putin hat
also es gibt keinen endokrinen der sowas
hat und oder in anderen europäischen
Ländern er könnte das vielleicht
versuchen und dann wenn es ihm gelingt
wenn Putin das klingt natürlich jetzt
nicht sehr realistisch aber dann würde
er doch vielleicht in die Geschichte
nicht eingehen als alles Putin Lob ist
und jemand der diesen kriegt vielleicht
auch herbeigeführt hat durch seinen
handeln und es geht auch darum dass das
die Politik hier auch reinen Tisch macht
es gibt nicht nur Herren Schröder es
gibt viele andere Probleme
ganz kurz
zu vermitteln
heißt das ja Botschafter dass sie wollen
dass Gerd Schröder Vermittler wird
zwischen dem Westen und Russland das ist
ja eine sehr spannende Forderung
das ist nur ein ein kreativer Vorschlag
und das liegt da an Herrn Schröder wo
ihr wo er jetzt in dieser Position ist
wo er sich alle von ihnen verabschieden
und abwenden warum denn nicht also wir
müssen jede Chance nutzen und das meine
ich ernst ich glaube nicht dass es etwas
zu vermitteln gibt im Ernst putin will
die Ukraine erobern und Russland
einverleiben und was sollte die
kompromissposition sein ein bisschen
erobern Jan silenski im Amt lassen nur
die Ostukraine nehmen die Krim behalten
und diese und jenes das ist ihm nicht
genug das hätte ja längst haben können
das geht einfach nicht wir müssen uns
damit abfinden
dieser Krieg den Putin begonnen hat den
Putin zu Ende führen will bei dem er
keine Zeichen von Rückzug erkennen lässt
muss man gewinnen über Putin man muss
Putin abservieren aber deswegen ich
werde wenn noch mal ein Punkt daraus kam
sie haben ihm gesagt der die Ukraine ist
verloren und da kann man nicht mehr viel
machen ja die ist aber das ist das ist
Herr Jörges das halte ich für ein ganz
großen Fehler das öffentlich zu sagen
das haben das haben wir genau das haben
wir ja von der Woche auch gehört bei
ronsheimer ein
solchesheimer hat das ja am Anfang der
Sendung auch noch mal hervorgehoben es
gab in Deutschland ich weiß das auch
noch aus den Diskussionen im Bundestag
viele die gesagt haben keine defensiv
Waffen an die Ukraine liefern das wird
eh nur zwei oder drei Tage dauern jetzt
sehen wir diesen hier ruhig heroischen
Kampf des ukrainischen Volkes und wir
sehen die brauchen weitere Unterstützung
die brauchen weitere Waffen wenn die
jetzt aber von uns hören na ja
eigentlich sind die schon verloren und
lass vielleicht den Putin sogar da mal
machen aber wir gucken dass der dann
nicht weitermacht dann wäre das ein ganz
ganz schlechtes Signal zumal Putin ja
nicht nur die Ukraine angreift sondern
ergreift damit auch unsere
demokratischen Werte an ergreift unsere
Freiheit an und er wird sich damit
möglicherweise nicht zufrieden gehen
wollen müssen wir hätten wir uns vor
drei Wochen hier in der Sendung
getroffen hätten sie und andere
wahrscheinlich gesagt na putin wird nie
nach Kiew einmarschieren das wird er gar
nicht wagen sondern da hätten viele
gesagt na ja vielleicht in du Hans und
Donald was denn noch was genau es haben
viele gesagt so und jetzt sehen wir was
Putin alles macht und wir wissen aus der
Geschichte solche Diktatoren solche
Autokraten solche verrückten die machen
meistens nicht nur bei einem Land Halt
und deswegen müssen wir eine Stärke
entwickeln und wir müssen mehr ins
Militär investieren wir müssen die
Ukraine jetzt unterstützen
ich habe nichts anderes gesagt ich
meinte damit natürlich kann Putin
militärisch die Ukraine besetzen wenn er
mit genug oben einrückt aber er besiegt
die Uhr alleine nicht weil er wird immer
auf Widerstand stoßen es wird immer
wieder Besetzung geben Paul wenn Paulus
oder Zwischenruf ist meistens mitnehmen
die die genau die Situation in Kiel
gerade in diesem Moment nach langer Ruhe
wieder Sirenenalarm zumindest gerade
einmal hier
jetzt hören Sie es ich lass mal leise
so hört sich der
Sirenenalarm in Kiew an
das was wir auch schon vor zwei Tagen
gehört haben also das ist die Realität
für die Bevölkerung hier jeden Tag
insbesondere dann wenn es dunkel wird
ich habe schon mal erklärt wir haben ein
weiteres Sicherheitssystem ausgestattet
auch mit Apps ähnlich wie in Israel wo
gewarnt wird von Luftschlägen von daher
gehen wir beim ich sage mal
einfacheren
Luftalarm noch nicht in den Bunker
sondern warten ein bisschen aber ich
glaube diese Stimmung muss man einmal
verstehen die wirklich grauenhaft ist
für die Menschen hier ich möchte Herrn
plossmann von Paul geben wir ganz kurz
in hier in eine ganz kurz Unterbrechung
lassen auch noch mal die Sirenen
nachhaltig auf uns wirken und hoffen
dass Paul dann auch gleich uns noch
zugeschaltet ist und das
selbstverständlich nicht zu einem
zweiten Alarm kommt Paul bis gleich
[Musik]
wir sind alle anders wir sind alle
gleich das ist das diesjährige Bild
Talk bei Bild sonntags die richtigen
Fragen Dienstag bis Donnerstag 8:15 Uhr
Montag und Freitag reif ist live
und eine der längsten und gefährlichsten
Operationen in der Geschichte der
Bundeswehr
wir sind zurück bei viertel nach acht
nach einer kurzen Unterbrechung und wir
sind auch alle noch da vor der Werbung
gingen bei pauronsheimer live in Kiew
das erste Mal die Sirenen an der erste
Alarm bis zum zweiten wird er aber bei
uns in der Sendung bleiben der
hoffentlich nicht eintreten wird das
hoffen wir alle ganz fest jetzt gehen
wir aber erstmal zum ukrainischen
Botschafter andre Melnik der heute ein
versorgungskorridor gefordert hat und
ich würde gerne wissen Herr Mennig was
hat es denn damit auf sich was für ein
Konzept steckt dahinter ja wir versuchen
seit den letzten Tagen auch die Ampel
der Regierung davon zu überzeugen dass
wir jetzt dringend nicht nur die Frage
der Waffenlieferungen auf den Tisch
legen und schauen dass wir nicht nur mit
diesen kleineren Geräten also Anti
Panzer Raketen dass die Ukraine
ausgestattet werden sondern dass man
auch dass das schwere Gerät unzuliefern
das was jetzt auf Lager ist das was
jetzt nicht gebraucht wird in
Deutschland oder in der nächsten Wochen
aber wir brauchen auch für die Menschen
vor Ort die jetzt seit Tagen gar nicht
die Kelle verlassen konnten weil der
Beschuss ununterbrochen
liefe weil weil keine Lebensmittel mehr
da sind wir haben gesehen diese Bilder
die Paul und seiner gerade heute gefilmt
hat in einem Supermarkt in Kiew das
heißt da müssen wir auch dringend ein
Konzept herstellen nicht nur vielleicht
mit deutschen aber Deutschland könnte da
eine wichtige Rolle spielen über Polen
ein Landweg damit die Städte versorgt
werden Kraftstoff fehlt Lebensmittel
Medizin also das sollte koordiniert
werden und ich glaube dass die
handballregierung aber auch die
bundesrepubliker ist als solche auf die
Landesregierung sind da glaube ich in
der Pflicht zu schauen zu helfen war was
was da getan werden kann und heute hatte
ich eine Schaltung mit mit einem mit
ihrem Kollegen Axel Müller aus
Ravensburg und da gab es schon Ideen
also was kann man da machen vielleicht
Pulver Nahrung dass das schnell
geliefert werden kann damit die Menschen
dann quasi mit dem was sie haben verorte
versorgt werden können das heißt gute
Idee liegt auf dem Tisch und wir hoffen
dass die Bundesregierung dass die
Politik dass die Menschen auch dieses
Konzept unterstützen denn es geht um
dort oder Leben von von vielen
Zivilisten die einfach unter beschossen
leben müssen und ausharren müssen
inwiefern hier gerade wurde schon
angesprochen Christoph dein Kollege was
hältst du von diesem versorgungskorridor
wie schätzt du es ein wie muss
Deutschland jetzt gerade mithelfen
Vorgehen vielleicht auch wie die ganzen
europäischen Länder zusammen ja das ist
auch ein ganz wichtiger Punkt der ich
auf der einen Seite reden wir über
Waffenlieferungen damit sich das
ukrainische Volk verteidigen kann aber
auf der anderen Seite müssen wir
natürlich auch diese humanitäre
Katastrophe im Blick haben und die
vielen unschuldigen Zivilisten die davon
betroffen sind deswegen da gibt es denke
ich gar nichts bei Meinungen dass das
absolut unterstützenswert ist ich will
noch mal einen Hinweis nur geben wir als
CDU zum Beispiel in Hamburg und auch
viele Kollegen in ganz Deutschland die
unterstützen solche Initiativen und sind
auch im Gesprächen mit der ukrainischen
der Sporer vor Ort und helfen wo man
helfen kann aber es ist häufig
sinnvoller dass auch über
Hilfsorganisationen zu machen die auch
eine große Expertise haben als das jetzt
jeder einzelne versucht irgendwie ein
paar Sachen zu sammeln und die dann
vielleicht sogar selber irgendwo hinzu
sondern da wirklich auch sehr stark auf
die Hilfsorganisation zu setzen dass man
sich das anschaut das ist sieht zum
Beispiel auf Instagram wie Menschen dann
dort selber an die Grenze fahren um das
zu tun ist da nicht vielleicht bringt es
mehr bei einer Hilfsorganisation aber
ist das als Symbol nicht viel mehr was
uns alle miteinander Verein als wenn man
Geld nur spendet das ist auch super man
muss das auch immer im Einzelfall sich
anschauen das kann man jetzt schwer
pauschal sagen aber es gibt ja ganz
viele in Deutschland die fragen sich wo
kann ich helfen und wie kann ich helfen
und was mache ich am besten und da gibt
es unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten
manchmal ist es tatsächlich auch
sinnvoll eine Geldspende zu tätigen weil
man weiß dann kommt das ganz schnell
auch an und es gibt auch Profis die sich
darum kümmern dass das schnell zu den
ukrainischen Menschen kommt als dass man
jetzt selber versucht so eine Logistik
aufzubauen ich wollte nur einmal diesen
Hinweis geben weil nicht viele
tatsächlich auch aus sehr guten Motiven
sagen ach ich versuche jetzt selber das
irgendwie dahin zu bringen und das ist
nicht immer sinnvoll also die
Hilfsorganisation die haben natürlich
eine sehr große Expertise und Erfahrung
ich möchte gerne drei Fragen an Sie
stellen die Sie ganz einfach beantworten
können ohne lange Erklärung erstens sind
sie dafür alle Energieimporte aus
Russland zu beenden zweitens bin ich da
sind sie dafür alle russischen Banken
aus Drift auszuschließen ja gut drittens
sind sie dafür ein handelssembargo gegen
Russland zu verhängen wenn ich auch sehr
dafür ich glaube die aktuellen Maßnahmen
die reichen noch nicht aus und wir sind
auch dafür härtere ja mit beiden Händen
ja das ist also ich bin genau wie sie
der Meinung Herr Görges eben haben wir
hart gestritten aber hier hier teile ich
ihre Meinung Russland muss isoliert
werden Russland muss noch viel stärker
mit Sanktionen belastet werden wir
brauchen einen umfassendes
Handelsembargo weil nur wenn Russland
das richtig spürt und Russland auch kaum
mehr die Möglichkeit hat Gas und Öl
irgendwohin zu verkaufen dann wird es
dort zu einem Umdenken kommen und wenn
wir sagen naja wir wollen doch noch ein
bisschen Gas beziehen und ein bisschen
und auch ein bisschen Öl dann ist das
nicht zielführend weil das immer noch
dazu führt dass Russland genügend Gelder
im Staatshaushalt hat und dann auch gut
überleben kann während es gleichzeitig
das ukrainische
Vorschläge man hat endlich begonnen auch
die Yachten von von Superreichen hier in
Deutschland zu beschlagnahmen das hätte
man vor vor Jahren tun müssen und mein
Vorschlag ist dass man sofort das was
man hat in der Hand dass der deutsche
Staat verkauft und dafür auch die
Menschen in der Ukraine und auch der
Wiederaufbau in der Ukraine des von
heute es beginnen sollte finanziert
werden kann das ist auch die Idee dass
auch die die konnten der Zentralbank
Russlands oder von anderen Banken das
dass das muss alles beschlagen
beschlagnahmt werden nicht nur jetzt
eingefroren oder es muss ein Verfahren
gefunden werden damit man wirklich
diejenigen trifft und nicht nur trifft
sondern wirklich das Geld von ihnen
wegnimmt und das Geld sofort
anderen Menschen die jetzt da sind und
Leiden zu helfen ich verstehe das und
auch ich bin für Sanktionen gegenüber
Russland ganz klar aber manchmal frage
ich mich auch wir haben uns zu lange
aber das hat Deutschland getan von einem
Despoten energietechnisch abhängig
gemacht das ist so Herr Beck hat heute
ja auch noch mal gesagt dass wir
energietechnisch schon abhängig sind
deswegen ist meine Frage der natürlich
auch an Dich wie wollen wir das jetzt so
schnell umsetzen also wir sagen wir
sagen zu mir in Russland mit allem wie
machen wir das mit der Energie in
Deutschland gut es gibt ja auch die
Möglichkeit auf lng-terminal zu setzen
aus meiner Sicht muss auch die Kernkraft
eine Option bleiben über das Jahr hinaus
wir müssen auch über das Thema Kohle
noch mal reden und gucken dass wir mit
Partnern wieder in USA aber auch in
arabischen Bereich versuchen das
fehlende Gas auszugreifen
genau
es wird sich der Gaspreis dann
vermutlich verdoppeln weil es viel
kostet aber das ist das ist ein ganz
entscheidender Punkt da will ich noch
mal das Aufgaben was Herr Jörg gesagt
natürlich werden ganz harte Sanktionen
wird ein umfassendes Handels embargo
auch uns treffen und wir werden das in
den Preisen merken aber es ist doch nur
glaubwürdig wenn wir nicht sagen sobald
es uns irgendwo auch selber berührt
lassen wir das und dann soll Putin
lieber weiter Geld bekommen um das
ukrainische Volk zu werden warum das
kann das kann doch nicht der Ansatz sein
aber da muss der Staat ja Zahlen der
Stadt dann gucken wir gerade die
ärmeren und diejenigen die das wirklich
auf finanziell hat trifft unterstützt da
gibt es ja unterschiedliche
Möglichkeiten mit Einmalzahlung mit
Steuersenkung das hat man so komisch der
vergleiche jetzt vielleicht erstmal
klingen mag aber wenn der corona-krise
haben wir ja gezeigt wie man auch dann
Hilfspakete schnüren kann aber ich finde
es völlig falsch wenn man sagt weil wir
hier selber keine Einschränkungen spüren
wollen kaufen wir weiter in russisches
Öl oder russisches Gas und finanzieren
damit ja Putins Krieg das kann nicht
sein dann können sie nur glaubwürdig
können doch nicht an diesem Krieg auch
noch verdienen genau gehen wir von
Russland subventionierte Preise genießen
das kann doch wohl nicht im Ernst sein
das heißt die EU-Kommission hat ja schon
ausgerechnet vor einiger Zeit dass die
Deutschen Lieferungen aus Russland 55%
des Gases 35% des Öls sofort zu ersetzen
wären aus anderen Quellen sofort zu
hören Preisen aber die müssen wir dann
eben in Kauf nehmen und dann müssen wir
sehen wie wir damit umgehen und da
müssen wir Leuten die sich die hören
Energiepreise nicht leisten können einen
Ersatz geben natürlich aus der
Staatskasse was immer das dann bedeutet
aber jedenfalls nur so ist eine ethisch
fundierte Politik in diesem Krieg
überhaupt denkbar
es müssen einige Lebenslügen über Bord
geworfen werden also wenn ich ich habe
mit den Grünen ja viele Diskussionen
gehabt die haben immer gesagt eine
Kernkraft geht gar nicht da müssen wir
raus aus Kohle müssen wir sofort raus
auch das muss man hinterfragen denn wir
werden nur eine
grundlastkapazität in der Energiepolitik
bekommen wenn wir auch jenseits der
Erneuerbaren da Optionen haben und
deswegen glaube ich müssen wir auch die
Debatte über Kernkraft neu in
Deutschland führen und wahrscheinlich
brauchen wir auch über dieses Jahr
hinaus Kernenergie in Deutschland die
Runde ist sich einig härteste Sanktionen
für Russland ich bin mir sicher Paul
dass du die Meinung auch teilst deswegen
kann ich sagen die Runde ist sich einig
oder siehst du das anders ist glaube ich
aber nicht nein das haben wir jetzt hier
schon mal gesagt und es war das zweite
leidenschaftliche Plädoyer von Herr
Ploss für die Kernenergie dass wir die
jetzt auch wieder nutzen gestern gab es
schon eins ich glaube das hat
Deutschland in den letzten Jahren nicht
gedacht dass man das hier mal erleben
wird in deutschen Talkshows und somit
kommen wir zum letzten Thema für heute
Abend und zwar zu dem von CDU-Politiker
Christoph Ploss
die schlimmen Ereignisse in der Ukraine
und der Angriffskrieg von Wladimir Putin
und von Russland auf das ukrainische
Volk die sind nicht nur verheerend in
der Ukraine und stellen eine Belastung
für ganz Europa da sondern sie werfen
natürlich auch in Deutschland viele neue
Fragen auf und eine der Fragen ist
brauchen wir die Wehrpflicht oder müssen
wir auch in Deutschland wieder die
Wehrpflicht einführen und ich bin der
Meinung wir brauchen nicht eine
Wehrpflicht wie wir sie früher
kennengelernt haben aber wir brauchen
eine allgemeine Dienstpflicht oder ein
gesellschaftsjahr in Deutschland das für
Männer und das für Frauen gleichermaßen
gilt jeder junge Mensch der sollte nach
der Schule entweder zur Bundeswehr gehen
der sollte wie früher beim Zivildienst
vielleicht in ein Pflegeheim gehen der
sollte in eine Einrichtung gehen wo
Menschen mit Behinderung wo Menschen mit
Behinderung geholfen wird wo es Ihnen
ermöglicht wird ins Alltagsleben im
Alltagsleben Fuß zu fassen es kann sein
dass es gut ist dass Menschen in eine
Erziehungsanstalt gehen es gibt ganz
viele soziale Einrichtungen im Land in
den gerade junge Menschen gebraucht
werden und wo es auch gut ist dass junge
Menschen mal rauskommen aus dem was sie
sonst so kennen dass sie mit sozialen
Problemen konfrontiert werden und
deswegen bin ich dafür wir brauchen mehr
Staatsbürger und wir brauchen weniger
ich-bürger in Deutschland und es kann
für den gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt
enorm hilfreich sein wenn Menschen nach
dem Schulabschluss ein gesellschaftsjahr
machen und etwas im sozialen Bereich tun
oder auch zur Bundeswehr gehen
wir brauchen weniger ich-bürger wir
brauchen mehr Staatsbürger das hör ich
in Deutschland in der corona-pandemie
seit zwei Jahren in Dauerschleife ich
muss ehrlich sagen ich möchte dass der
Ukraine geholfen wird und zwar zu dem
höchstmöglichen Maße ich bewundere
helmenig der heute in der Runde ist wie
sehr erkämpft für sein Land und auch ich
will das Deutschland Hilft Sanktionen
gehören dazu aber jetzt schon wieder
dass die jungen Leute schon wieder
entscheidet der Staat was die jungen
Leute in Deutschland machen sollen das
reicht und ich glaube auch nicht ich
würde die Frage ja direkt an Herr Melnik
schicken dass es ihrem Land jetzt hilft
wenn wir in Deutschland ein
gesellschaftsjahr machen und nach der
corona-pandemie wieder jungen Menschen
vorschreiben was sie jetzt am Abi zu tun
haben oder wir sehen uns
ich glaube dass das der Gedanke schon
richtig ist das denn Herr Dr bloß gerade
ausgedrückt hat denn wir brauchen schon
wir haben gesehen also der Staat hat
einen Wert und das erleben wir als
Ukraine denn ohne Staat haben wir viele
Jahrzehnte verbringen müssen ohne den
Staat und das heißt den Wert diese Stadt
ist zu erkennen was das auch für jeden
einzelnen Bürger bedeutet das hat man
das sieht man jetzt in der Ukraine man
kämpft ja nicht nur für den oneblock
oder für das Dorf sondern auch für
diesen ukrainischen Staat weil wenn es
Ihnen nicht geben sollte dann ist es
alles weg dann kann man alles vergessen
kann man den Wohlstand nicht mehr haben
dann kann man die Sprache vergessen das
alles wird verschwinden und deswegen ich
kann durchaus diese Meinung teilen ich
bürge ist wichtig Freiheit wir sind wir
eben auch Freiheit aber neben der
Freiheit ist die Staatlichkeit aus
unserer Sicht genauso zentral ich war
früher exakt derselben Meinung wie sie
ich habe dafür auch mehrfach geschrieben
weil mir das sehr einleuchtend
erschienen heute bin ich nicht mehr
dieser Meinung jedenfalls nicht mehr
vollständig weil ich glaube dass ein
soziales Pflichtjahr für junge Leute im
sozialen Bereich den Druck auf die
Gehälter die niedrigen Gehälter für die
Leute die dort fest arbeiten noch
verstärken wird wenn die die
Krankenhäuser die Sozialeinrichtungen
quasi kostenfrei junge Leute kriegen
bedeutet das dass die Leute die dort
arbeiten keine richtigen Argumente mehr
haben um ihre Gehälter zu verbessern ich
glaube um es kurz zu machen
dass wir die Wehrpflicht davon überzeugt
dass das richtig war die Wehrpflicht hat
eine große politische Tradition nämlich
das kann man heute kaum mehr sagen ohne
falsch verstanden zu werden das war als
sie geschaffen wurde wurde vom
Milizsystem gekauft da
Milizionäre Abstand genommen und es
wurde eine Volksarmee eingeführt die hat
beispielsweise dazu beigetragen Napoleon
aus aus Mittel- und Osteuropa zu
vertreiben nur so war das möglich es
sind Preußen eingeführt worden und war
eine politische Errungenschaft und diese
politische Errungenschaft das alle sich
für den Staat und seine Sicherheit
einzusetzen haben ist leichtfertig von
der CDU aufgegeben worden da haben viele
schon damals dran gezweifelt und heute
sind die Zweifel noch viel größer
geworden die Bundeswehr hatte damals als
es die Wehrpflicht noch gab doppelt
viele Soldaten wie sie heute hat und
heute mangelt ja nicht nur an Gerät es
mangelt auch an Menschen die in der
Bundeswehr dienen und deshalb ich stimme
Ihnen also partiell zu über den Rest
müsste man auch reden Wehrpflicht wieder
her aber da will ich da will ich mal
widersprechen weil wir haben ja kein
Problem die ganz dass die ganz vielen
offenen Stellen die es ja im gerade im
Pflegebereich gibt zu besetzen also es
würde ja nicht dazu führen wenn jetzt
ein junger Mensch im Bereich der Zeit
wenn jetzt ein wenn jetzt ein junger
Mensch im Bereich der Pflege hilft dann
wird das nie dazu führen dass eine
ausgebildete Pflegekraft kein Job
bekommt sondern das Gegenteil ist ja der
Fall wir haben ja hunderttausende offene
Stellen schon klar und ein junger Mensch
der nach der Schule beispielsweise bei
der Pflege hilft der macht ja nicht
genau das was ein ausgebildeter Pfleger
macht das darf der ja gar nicht deswegen
kann man das auch nicht so vergleichen
mir geht es eher darum dass man einfach
mal mit Problemen dieses Landes
konfrontiert wird dass junge Menschen
die vielleicht sonst behütet aufwachsen
danach ein Studium Sachen in einem Büro
sitzen im Glaskasten danach ihren
Porsche nach Hause fahren dass die auch
einen anderen Bereich mal sehen und auch
mit anderen Menschen zusammenkommen mit
denen sie sonst vielleicht nie
zusammenkommen würden und das ist für
den gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt ganz
ganz wichtig und es gibt im Land so viel
Bedarf an sozialen Tätigkeiten dass das
Argument da wird kann vielleicht eine
Pflegekraft dann nicht mehr arbeiten
einfach nicht gilt wir werden das nach
der Sendung bestimmen könnt ihr beiden
das dann ausdiskutieren ich möchte aber
die letzten zwei seine Minuten nutzen um
noch einen Eindruck von paroonsheimer
aus der Ukraine zu haben heute war der 8
Kriegstag Paul und vielleicht eine
Minute lang kannst du noch mal die
Eindrücke schildern vielleicht auch für
Zuschauer die erst später eingeschaltet
haben
ja also der Sirenenalarm ist wieder weg
tatsächlich war es heute vergleichsweise
ruhig tagsüber was sicherlich mit den
vermeintlichen Friedensgesprächen zu tun
gehabt hat nur da darf man sich leider
nichts vormachen das ist die Taktik die
Wladimir Putin auch schon in Syrien
benutzt hat er nutzt Friedensgespräche
um zu sagen schaut her ich will ja
keinen Krieg gegen die Zivilisten führen
und dann wenige Tage später nutzte das
als Begründung um zu sagen dass alle die
jetzt noch im Kessel von Kiew sind
sozusagen Feinde sind Nazis sind und das
ist das ähm was er rhetorisch
vorbereitet deswegen müssen wir davon
ausgehen dass die schweren Waffen die
schon in anderen Teilen des Landes
eingesetzt werden jetzt auch bald in
Kiew eingesetzt werden ich habe vor
einer Stunde das letzte Mal mit Vitali
Klitschko telefoniert den Bürgermeister
von Kia viel bereitet man sich auf
Häuserkampf am Ende vor ich glaube nicht
dass es zum Häuserkampf kommt so schnell
sondern es wird zum Einsatz von vielen
Raketen kommen es wird möglicherweise
Einkesselung kommen der Stadt und das
bedeutet dass es dann schwierig sein
wird hier noch Medizin reinzubekommen
hier noch Lebensmittel reinzubekommen so
ist die traurige Lage gleichzeitig
appelliere ich so ein bisschen auch an
die Zuschauer und an uns alle
Journalisten sozusagen nicht nur in
Anführungszeichen nach Kiew zu schauen
denn wir sehen das in vielen weiteren
Teilen des Landes und die Ukraine ist
ein riesen Land mit 60 Millionen danke
ich Sendezeit ist vorbei das tut mir
leid ich danke euch
pass auf Dich auf Paul ja pass auf Dich
auf Paul danke mache ich dankeschön für
deine Arbeit bis morgen Abend wieder
dann sind wir wieder hier bei viertel
nach acht paul und ich werden auch
morgen abend wieder da sein um 20 Uhr
schönen Abend noch
[Musik]